mira muchas gracias primero por la
invitación
perdón que estoy con mis hijos en casas
los niños están en otros grupos acabamos
de subir del refugio acaba de sonar la
sirena donde estoy hace 20 minutos así
que están un poco pasados okay así que
los niños se asustan no hay mucho que
hacer con eso pero como para contestar
tu pregunta hay varios factores para
definir qué es lo que está pasando acá
primero tenemos una contextualización
dentro de la política palestina tenemos
a mahmud abás que te había llamado a
elecciones y las canceló eso significa
que los palestinos llevan 16 años sin
elecciones lo que enojó mucho a hamás
que son los que gobiernan en la franja
de gaza y en disputa pone a vásquez de
la autoridad nacional palestina ellos
dijeron que se cancelaban las elecciones
jerusalén y barber esto se está usando
como una excusa política interna de
ellos por otra parte tenemos las
exacerbaciones del mes de ramadán donde
tenemos células extremistas de
musulmanes dentro de los feligreses que
están rezando todos los días en la
ciudad vieja de jerusalén
y llamaron la violencia le pegaron a
gente intentaron linchar y tenemos sea
todo un contexto que se empezó a
difundir en diferentes focos que llevó a
que jamás subiera la cantidad de misiles
que hasta como ustedes dijeron el día de
hoy después de casi tres días de
escalada llegaron a 1600 ahora si van
qué papel está jugando entonces este
movimiento islamista hamás que gobierna
la franja de gaza además al fatah de
mahmud abás y la autoridad palestina
o sea acá él es totalmente un 'tira y
afloja' como se dice jamás es el que
está intentando manejar todo a su manera
y tratando de manipular los hechos
presionando israel con misiles que
llegan hasta tel aviv hasta jerusalén
hace dos días atrás tienen misiles de la
franja de gaza y jerusalén hay 100
kilómetros de la franja de gaza donde
estoy yo hay 80 kilómetros o sea no
estamos hablando de piedritas estamos
hablando de misiles de alto alcance el
otro día ayer fue dos misiles
antitanques se dispararon desde gaza
hacia israel y uno de ellos impactó en
un auto también en matando a dos
personas
esto es todo un tira y afloje pero
israel no va a permitir que se ataque a
su población civil con mil 600 misiles
ahora ustedes mostraron antes las
imágenes que se derrumbó un edificio en
casa israel está bombardeando blancos
estratégicos de hamás ustedes también lo
explicaron que lo que estás buscando
deshabilitar al grupo terrorista como
hamas es un grupo terrorista islamista
el objetivo del ejército israel nunca
van a ser los civiles jamás si o sea
dentro de los muertos de israel hay
árabes también que viven dentro de
israel entonces hamas no le importa
donde caen los misiles es lo que hay que
entender también que israel avisa dentro
del territorio de hamás cuando va a
bombardear para desalojar si van
hablemos ahora del primer ministro
benjamin netanyahu y cómo quedan sus
fuerzas después de este nuevo estallido
de la violencia
eran detallado hasta una posición ahora
estamos justo en la mitad de formación
de gobierno información de coalición la
gente que no se olvide que pasamos
elecciones y en de tania o no pudo
formar coalición no pudo llegar a los 61
mandatos que necesita para hacer un
nuevo gobierno y lo estaban invitando a
ser ahora sus contrincantes y aísla pitt
conjunto con neftalí benet que estaban
formando intentando formar un gobierno
pero el comité de seguridad de israel
sigue funcionando y lápiz de hecho es
parte del benny gantz es ministro
defensa que también es en contrario
netania o entonces él tiene que seguir
funcionando y tiene que seguir llevando
al país a una situación lo más segura
posible ahora si van es evidente que
existen las rivalidades y ha pasado
durante años pero le preguntó si podría
verse entonces algún tipo de
reconciliación ante tanta violencia
y reconciliación entre israelíes y
palestinos
digamos algún tipo de acuerdo entre
entre israel y palestina para que paren
estas hostilidades para que para los
enfrentamientos para que no siga
sufriendo la población civil
si jamás deja de bombardear a él se
retira
graciasivan por su tiempo por estar aquí
con nosotros en francés y cuatro que
tengo el resto de muchos